welcome back to dc thursday i'm pete
soderling i'm the founder of data
council and the data community fund
and i am your sherpa through the data
tooling ecosystem
uh excited to bring you another episode
of dc thursday where we talk with a
leader
of an open data company
meaning open source a tool author
and or founder of a data company in the
ecosystem that we think is interesting
and today i couldn't be more excited
to have rick lammers here rick is the
founder a co-founder and ceo of orcist
it's o-r-c-h-e-s-t dot io
uh and rick has an interesting
past in the open source data world he
started a a project called grid studio
which he'll tell us about uh several
years ago and he also has a master's in
computer science from delft university
of technology i dropped out
and you dropped out which i was going to
mention but okay
so rick i don't think it's the first
time we've had to drop out on the show
but i want to welcome you anyway
well i did finish another degree that
was in business um but i'm glad to be
here i'm glad to talk about all things
that we've been up to and i hope to be
able to share something useful with the
audience yeah thank you beaming all the
way in from the netherlands so um
correct you know we're excited to be
able to
to cross the pond and to have you here
so so rick uh typical question for us
around here at dc thursday is
what inspired you to get into data um
what's sort of the origin story of rick
and data
i think uh it's a good question because
it was a gradual process
i think it's just really aligns very
well with how my brain is wired
and with that i mean what really
fascinates me and interests me and where
i want to spend my time
and this was a slow process because even
though i had been coding since i was
pretty young i never really at that time
when i was building a bunch of web
applications and general application
engineering when i was like 15 i didn't
really realize that data would be the
kind of niche that would really really
interest me it was only until
much later when i got into university
start studying statistics
that i was really hooked i very vividly
remember
i had a course it was just called
statistics it was a very
a very introductory course on statistics
but it was um taught in r
so r was the main programming language
and we touched upon a whole bunch of
inference questions this was statistics
for business so it was about social
science and how to do inference and
hypothesis testing and p values and p
hacking and all those kind of usual
caveats and i was just extremely
hooked from the moment we were working
with real data sets and writing code to
analyze it because i had already seen
you know code doing interesting stuff um
on you know computers graphics
visualizing stuff applications games um
but i never really dove into that you
know combination of the abstractness of
data data analysis data you know
hypothesis testing uh inference
predictive models and combining that
with code and the moment i got into this
i was so i basically got an insatiable
hunger
for information and knowledge about this
field
from the moment of taking that course
and i think it's actually what led me to
after business school then go to study
computer science because i just wanted
to get more of that and um in in the
technical university of delft where i
went to
um it teaches these basic fundamental
courses so linear algebra predicate
calculus
statistics probability and um
and and uh calculus regular calculus and
so these these courses were really kind
of my
foundation that i needed to be able to
kind of advance to more sophisticated
concepts because for a lot of the you
know deep learning models you have
gradient descent based algorithms they
require you to be able to calculate the
you know the
take the derivative of the loss function
etc so it really gave me the tools i
needed to get much deeper into that
world of data and coding and i i haven't
really stopped since that moment that
moment was i think in 2015 where i got
that stats course and since that moment
i'm basically an addict
of the field
so you're a business a business student
who got
into computer science um through a stats
class basically i had to write a letter
to the university to get accepted to the
computer science program because they're
like what is this business guy doing
trying to code so i had to demonstrate
that i already knew how to code so for
me was mostly about teaching the
mathematical foundation um and uh that's
where i spent most of my time during the
undergraduate program i did for one year
i've never heard of a stats class as a
gateway drug but but there you go it is
definitely one it was for me
that's great um i love my stats class in
university i have to say that i do have
a similar
appreciation that they just sort of
opened up my world um and that was a
that was a very memorable course for me
as well
um so so then so so what happened next
you you started to go down the rabbit
hole of both data and computer science i
think you started to study more about
deep learning and sort of deeper algos
as well no
well i can talk about how this first
connection with statistics got me into
building great studio because
what what ended up happening was after
taking that first stats class i knew i
wanted to graduate in business school
for my master's thesis on a topic that
enviro involved significant data
analysis so i went to choose a topic and
i actually chose early company
evaluation so when a company is very
nascent how do you determine its value
using a data-driven approach and so
i worked in both microsoft excel
and rstudio and i was totally frustrated
with that experience of having to work
with both like the microsoft excel
export functionality and then the
analysis environment of rstudio that i
was just like you know i know how to
code why don't i just create something
that integrates these two environments
so like a rebel-oriented
programming environment but one of the
really nice things about rstudio is that
you can do line-by-line execution so i
took that idea but i kind of preferred
python over r so i was like let's build
a google sheet with a python interpreter
so that you can combine this kind of
spreadsheet environment with
python and i didn't really think about
it that much at the time but the reason
i needed a spreadsheet was actually
because i had to do a lot of data
cleaning and augmentation
to be able to even have the data to do
my research so that's why that was still
a useful concept for me to have to have
your manual data entry there as well and
that's what i then open sourced on
github
amazing and so what what was the
response from the community um when when
you open sourced the tool like how did
how did what did the adoption curve sort
of look like so i will give a cautionary
tale to not trust your first market
responses uh because when i initially
talked about grid studio in 2018 it i
didn't really consider to be an open
source thing at the time i just coded it
in the summer hadn't really thought
about uploading it anywhere it was just
something i had on my computer and a git
repo
and i um i talked to a bunch of people
about it actually talked about it with
the plotly founder uh i i messaged him
out of the blue on linkedin just talked
about what i built and want to just get
his opinion i was i knew i was very new
to the field so i i was just trying to
show what i had created to people and um
basically it was crickets like i told i
think 40 people and nobody really cared
but it was all people in my environment
so like people at the university
people in my friend group and everybody
just kind of not cared uh so i kind of
put it on a shelf didn't really do
anything with it and then just went out
uh to work on uh focus on the first year
of the master's in computer science i
had done the the bridging year by then
and um
then uh after that first year i was like
it's kind of collecting dust on the
shelf i don't think i'm gonna do
anything with it i just i'll just open
source it i'll just put it in public
domain apache2.0 and then i will
i will just maybe some some someone
looks at it and if not that's fine but
at least people can look at the code and
do something with it if they want to and
i it's very crazy was it this really
like rocket moment where i wrote on a
blog post and submitted it to hacker
noon
and it got accepted and i posted it to
reddit and i went to bed then i wake up
the next morning and its first first uh
page on both our programming and our
data science and it just happened to
start collecting a whole bunch of get up
stars and and truth to god i i i didn't
know about the concept of a git up star
at that at that moment so what actually
it triggered a whole bunch of events
that eventually led to me flying out to
san francisco and talking to a whole
bunch of interesting people
but basically that's that's how great
studio then got attention from you know
the programming community i think
because the
you know the concept of building your
own spreadsheet because i had
re-implemented the spreadsheet myself as
a learning exercise and then combining
that with something like python which is
a very you know definitely at that point
was very up-and-coming popular language
now it's a very dominant popular
language um i think that just sparked
interest with people so i think people
came at it with an educational interest
like how would you build such a thing
and we definitely had some people that
wanted to use it as well but that was um
that was that experience and i think for
me it really cemented that you don't
really know at the data point of like 40
people telling you something of a very
very biased sample
it's only until you get it out in front
of many people where you know whether
something is interesting to people or
not
and how um how did you like how did the
interest in the project peak at what
point um did the interest peak and and
why did you decide not to continue
building grid studio if uh if there was
demand for it
yeah so
i it was very like immediate because i
just uploaded it to github that was the
first time i shared it if you look at
the repo history you see like i built it
over the summer of 2018 then i open
sourced it on like
august 2nd of 2019 so one year later and
then it just
got all of that attention through the
article so the article described the
whole reasoning behind behind why i
created it and it also explains at the
end of the article why i didn't want to
consent continue with it or considered
it to be like a viable project for
starting a company or something because
to me a superior option would be just to
use uh microsoft the real microsoft
excel
with something like excel wings which is
this open source library that lets you
run python
inside um your microsoft excel because i
didn't really see the like you would
need to re-implement everything of a
spreadsheet program and mine was
browser-based so you'd basically be
implementing google sheets and i knew
how big of an like exercise that would
be and then like you could try to build
an add-on for google sheets which i
think was a more viable path to getting
that kind of product out and i just
didn't really see
um you know i was way more interested in
different things at that point as well
like i i like i said i created in 2018
and in 2019 i was already thinking about
like the the key ideas of orchest and i
was not so interested anymore in you
know combining spreadsheets with an
interpreter even though it was a fun
idea just to play around with it got it
um well this is a good point to to
remind the audience that if they have
questions for you they can jump in the
chat because um obviously you know just
from this little backdrop it's obvious
that you have experience with product
development um with open source projects
and we'll talk about orchest um as we go
throughout the show more
um but if folks are interested in um any
company building advice that you might
have um or questions about orcas for the
products that you've built i'd invite
them to jump in the chat and we'll get
to the questions as as we can
um
so so you said you were already sort of
you had moved on mentally and you were
thinking about new ideas um apparently
the ideas that would germinate uh orcas
the product which was what you started
to build next um tell me about about
that process and what you were what you
were discovering
yeah so
in university basically two key things
stood out to me so one was obviously the
deep learning revolution you had john
the [ __ ] joffrey hinton all these really
famous researchers now famous
for inventing a way to actually make
neural networks feasible because they
had been invented quite a bit of time
ago but i think we now have the compute
the the data
amounts needed to actually train these
like highly parameterized models and
also the algorithmic
uh
innovation so back propagation
implemented efficiently at a hardware
layer in gpus right that was really
necessary um and so everybody was
talking about what was happening in that
area convolutional neural networks with
this really good bias of you know the
convolutional kernel with the space
invariants that it it kind of
has as a prior
and so this was super interesting stuff
to me so uh basically decomposing what
was happening in the field of machine
learning and predictive models that were
growing ever ever more parameters but
even the fundamentals about like
predictive models and understanding
their complexity so you have this thing
called the colemo grove complexity which
tries to measure kind of how many
different data points it can represent
or how many classifications it could
make i'm probably watching the
explanation but the key point was i was
really getting drawn into that world of
like the predictive modeling side and
the innovation that was happening there
at the same time i was taking stuff like
compiler courses where i was
re-implementing a java bytecode compiler
where we're just trying to
implement a compiler from scratch by
working on the ast representation and
what really stood out to me there the
whole course was focused on dsls so
um we were implementing all our own kind
of dsls and adding all kinds of ide
language features to that and it really
dawned on me that that course um talked
about abstractions and the right
abstractions and the right abstractions
relative to the domain and with that
lens i looked at sql and went like ah
that's actually a really good
abstraction over how to think about
working with table structures right with
structured data sets because it hides
all kinds of complexity
when you're working with raw files that
contain lines and jsons on lines like
those types of like you easily forget uh
how much of that complexity is just all
gone if you're using a structured
database like a postgres or my sequel
and um to me what i what i really felt
was a need for to combine those ideas so
i really liked what was happening in
predictive models and what you could do
with them in applied context so
i'm a real company i have a real
question i would like to give a
data-driven answer i would like to have
data-driven automation so maybe
predictive you know endpoints predictive
inference but then i felt that a lot of
the people in the industry so the you
know the practitioners on the ground i
was joining companies part time as a
freelancer to work on data projects for
them so i was doing some actual grunt
work myself at a company called dot link
i worked with them as kind of a data
scientist last data engineer and for me
this this like we're at the wrong level
of abstraction it was like the the main
thing that stood out to me and i always
enjoyed uh building software that's used
by uh technical users so like thinking
about better toolboxes because it's like
i like the steve jobs quote of like
bicycle for the mind as like as a
general metaphor for a computer and i i
like that as a kind of challenge to like
figure out like how can we be smarter
about the tools we create how can we be
smarter about the abstractions we create
there's so much interesting work in
compiler theory where you're abstracting
many concepts to make compilers more
generic so you can have a separate front
end of the compiler that can take uh
that can map to an arbitrary backend of
the compiler and these are really
powerful concepts because they provide
you leverage like you you solve the
general case you have these really clean
points of um
interfaces where you're not really
concerned with what goes on below that
level
and to me there was just very exciting
you know feeding ground to think about
new ideas and how to do this better and
that's where where where orca started to
came come in and it was really about the
concept of dags because you you
basically find dags everywhere in data
processing and in data projects right
it's fundamentally about what's the
relationship between data
and how is that relationship driving the
computation and how can you actually
structure a project where that
relationship between execution and data
flows is manageable and understandable
and sometimes even
generic or generalizable where you could
reuse certain things and make them more
modular so it just i think that was the
the starting concept that we started
orcas with is how to think about the dag
in a pretty fundamental way as it
relates to the workflow of data
scientists
doing these things in practice and this
is because you had some experience that
led you to believe that the the
pipelining of the data prior to the
actual analysis or
algorithmic work on it was was
challenging was complex and you
apparently didn't like the existing
tooling that was already out there
yeah i felt a lot of the existing
tooling was too purpose-built and
complex and i think the the concept of a
notebook to me it was so powerful when
you first use a notebook it immediately
becomes clear that this kind of repel
environment breeds a lot of fast
iteration and exploration of data which
is totally key if you're working on some
sort of analysis i think a lot of the
tooling was actually built more for the
data engineering domain or
paradigm of i know upfront what i want
to do
but i just need a way to do it
as a system that works reliably and this
kind of um you know problem has been
around for a long time because a lot of
people have had to feed and create data
warehouses and basically create reliable
and robust infrastructure for managing
data flows and systems but i think the
the much more nascent bit which also
plays into the predictive modeling side
of things is the kind of predictive and
analytical question that can come after
you have all those systems reliably
collecting and and making available data
for analysis so what to me was really
interesting is like what how do you
structure the process of analysis using
something like a dac because to me it
was pretty clear that when you ask any
data scientist very often a lot of the
analysis actually involves a lot of
transformations and what you could call
etl but the goal is not to to then
transform the data to get it into a data
warehouse in a different shape it's
really to answer questions to train a
model so it might be around feature
engineering it might be around
you know really just collapsing
information increasing or decreasing the
resolution so you might want to go from
like monthly to daily samples or from
some other way so you might do like
computing of values and so a lot of this
etl came about like
like with the goal of analysis and i
think that to do that in a single
notebook was to me not not very
intuitive so that's why i was thinking
about like how do you introduce a dag um
that then combines that with notebook
but really with the purpose of the
analysis and not necessarily the
the data transformations you will see in
a typical data warehousing so the so the
whole idea it sounds like it's um it's
dags for data scientists it's not dags
for analytics engineers or
data engineers or analytic systems
it's it's this notion that oh data
scientists
um could benefit from the dag notion and
there's not easy tooling for them to be
able to to chain together
processes and and transformations of
data
in a simplistic environment that they
can use that's perhaps no notebook based
or python based or sort of in their
universe of tooling
yep yep totally and so we called we
called uh we called it data science
pipelines initially but not a lot of
people got what that meant they felt
almost like a misspelling do you mean
data pipelines for data scientists so we
kept hearing that more and more often
that we just said like okay we'll
position it as it it's for it's for data
pipelining you could still use regular
like perform regular etl in it uh even
writing to data warehouse like you have
all kind of potential integrations to
just do regular etl but then i would
probably refer you to like the more
traditional etl stack like maybe
something like luigi or airflow i think
that is a more suitable choice but then
for like the the analytical bit that's
why we have first class support built in
for notebooks that's where i think the
the really interesting bit comes in like
how do you combine dags for analytical
purposes where the pipeline doesn't
necessarily do a traditional you know
data movement task or data
transformation task but really is about
preparing the data in a um
easily understandable way to to serve
the
served analysis serve the model fitting
or data visualization
yeah
got it and so how did you initially
validate this idea with customers or
potential customers like who are you
talking to to socialize
this notion that you had and what sort
of feedback did you get
yeah we we just talked to as many people
that we could talk to that we felt were
in a position that reflected the type of
problem we wanted to focus on so we
talked mostly to i would say lead data
scientists data science architects like
people in a position where they're
typically tasked with spearheading how
do we approach this initiative because
um sometimes you know in very small
teams it was just the data science team
itself so we had teams of three people
that
basically
uh you know everybody's kind of the
leader and the owner it's not really a
hierarchical structure but sometimes you
have like larger orgs 25 data scientists
you have one person that has done a
couple of these things before and they
might have a good idea of like how to go
about this how do we set things up where
do we store the data how do we version
the code like all these kind of
operational things you call those you
call those data science architects i
don't think i've heard that term before
is that like uh
is that so i'm not sure if it's
industry standard nomenclature um so
basically on linkedin people have these
different uh like titles that they self
get them so
you also have chief data scientists
which we saw very often like but they're
basically like the main main person
but some of them had really this
architect role like they're the
they're really designing the whole
system like what are the components
where
where where do we store everything
where's the compute uh running so i
don't know i feel like around titles
people are figuring stuff out but um
these were the types of people we were
interested in speaking to because they
typically had pretty good ideas about
the requirements like they had in mind
like what they wanted to be able to do
and
what they um had gotten stuck on in the
past and so talking to them was very
insightful because we could validate uh
ideas like data scientists want to still
be able to use notebooks like one of the
things that we heard over and over again
when talking to people and we actually
felt it a little bit ourselves but it
was great to see that confirmed is you
typically get people start off in a
notebook then to get something to
production they often have to move out
of a notebook then they put it in
production and then they want to iterate
but then the shape of the project is no
longer amenable to iteration as much
because you don't really have the
reptile anymore and so we started asking
some fundamental questions to ourselves
like
why
can't you just keep using a notebook and
a lot of people are like because the
industry says you can't it's like
notebooks can't be productionized
because that's bad for certain reasons
and
we actually started doing a bit of like
first principles like why can't you do
this like what is a notebook okay it's a
json object it contains source code it
can contain output it has a little bit
of metadata about like the kernel um so
so we started thinking about this and we
actually didn't really find a reason why
you can't just let the code still be in
notebooks but there were some some
obvious potential problems that you need
to solve in a good way and so the way we
solve for example
not getting these monolithic notebooks
that are really hard to understand
because of you know the state problem
like you could have state that
accumulates people working with
notebooks probably get this you might
need to understand can this run top to
bottom so we were like
multiple notebooks like you can have
multiple notebooks smaller notebooks so
that alleviates a little the state
reasoning issue
so that was one thing then another thing
around versioning is you could actually
just fully version notebooks as text
files uh there's a really cool jupyter
lab extension that does this as a plugin
for jupyter labs it's called jupytext
and it basically just encodes the full
json objects as text and only the source
code so you never version the output in
there because versioning the output
would make it hard to diff right diffing
the the notebook so we started
addressing one on one after one like the
issues with using notebooks uh in
production so that the goal was you
build a pipeline with notebooks you
productionize it you might want to
improve stuff because you learn
something from productionizing and you
can be in the same environment and so
that whole iteration just becomes much
faster um and and you know that was a
big part of what we validated with uh
just by talking to people
and at the time um was had you heard of
the other sort of larger tech companies
netflix and others who might have been
running notebook notebooks in production
or starting to take steps to potentially
sort of
unlock that as well
so obviously we we used a lot of like
what's available on the internet just to
kind of explore what the landscape
looked like because you know a
conversation with someone planning that
is very expensive you need to ask them
and like they need to make time so what
we did in addition was a lot of what we
call netgraphies like it's like looking
on the internet just to absorb as much
information as you can about like what's
being done current approaches so we saw
stuff like the
um the library from netflix that lets
you parameterize notebooks and execute
them
papermill right and so
so many tools you know this so it's hard
to remember all the names but papermill
was one of those libraries where we
could see that netflix had a little bit
of a think tank going
think tank where people were getting
together thinking about interesting ways
to build better tooling suites for their
data analysis teams
but we could also see at the same time
that you know michelangelo
the platform developed i think at uber
and big head at airbnb those were both
described
at conferences as these platform
initiatives but i think everybody was
hoping for them to come to market to
have like this open source solution that
people could use but i think
these companies realized how hard it is
to actually solve these types of
platform type questions in the general
case and obviously as a company
typically you have a pretty specific
text technology stack so you don't
really have to think about like how do i
solve this for all kinds of scenarios
and environments you can keep the
constraints pretty you know
tight around your needs and so
when we saw that these companies had
trouble open sourcing these things for
whatever reason but also saw that there
was a lot of work internally to make
these tools available to support the
data analysis efforts we felt that there
was a real kind of like why don't we do
this as a like separate company separate
product that we could then offer to all
kinds of people at various companies so
that not every company in the world has
to invent their own
full stack to support this analytical
work
got it got it
and so so let's talk about the
the early stages of the company um
when did you incorporate how did you
find your co-founder um who was the
early team like talk to me about
you know i mean obviously you had a
business degree before so maybe maybe
starting a company wasn't as
daunting for you well i was purely a
technical person but there's still like
a hurdle to get across right so talk to
me about
what what concerned you most and how you
got through some of those hurdles early
on
so
in the beginning the question was a lot
about opportunity costs so what is the
what's the most meaningful impactful
thing you could be pursuing
and uh i was working on research and
predictive modeling where we
thought about regularization so we're
working on formalizing dropout
regularization in the abstract sense
generalizing as well to for example
sequential models and so that felt like
a very interesting domain to me but at
the end of the day what i
really thought i could be good at and
what i would really enjoy doing is
being a person that kind of
creates this amplification effect of a
broad class of people uh the technical
practitioners who call themselves either
data scientists or machine learning
engineers or researchers
sometimes even data analysts depending
on you know the definition and the skill
set of the person but it just felt super
exciting to have that as your user like
to me those are the people i want to
work for like if i work the entire day
and night for months or years
and it's for them to do a better job to
bring bring a more data driven
perspective to their way of working and
to really automate stuff based on
you know
the the kind of tools that are now being
developed both in academia but then
being brought to industry to me it just
felt like the most exciting thing ever
so
to be able to then get an opportunity to
work with some of the best people in the
industry as your investors through the
attraction that grit studio got i was
like okay well this is like
the best thing that i could do right now
so why don't i just go head first in and
i had to say no to the graduation
process of my computer science thesis
which i've worked really hard towards to
to be able to do but eventually i don't
regret it because building this company
with the people we now have at the
company we have a fantastic team of
engineers i think they're all super
passionate about getting this problem
solved in the right way they're super
passionate about product like to me this
is just the most exciting thing i could
be working on so in terms of when we
started the company when i got the
traction of brit studio in the summer of
2019 so this was uh august 2019 i flew
out to the bay area talked to a bunch of
folks got back to the netherlands
discussed with yanik my co-founder about
starting this company i just described
what i had experienced in san francisco
he offered himself to co-found a company
with me but i already known him for a
long time and i knew he was excited
about
building his own company setting his own
culture for like having a engineering
first organization where engineers are
not treated as a cost center all these
kind of ideas he had which was very
atypical he was studying mathematics so
the fact that he had these ideas was to
me very interesting signal that he could
be a good potential co-founder and so we
started then working on the first
prototype this was november december
2019 we ended up doing the precede in
like early 2020 so this was around
february and then we worked on that um
and like for 12 months we built our
product we got more users and then we
did our series seed uh in july this year
so that's been like the journey um so
far awesome awesome yeah well that's uh
i remember meeting you and and yannick
in sf and probably
january
january 2020 um
just before the pandemic and that was
that was when we first met and so
it's been great to be able to support
you in the company since then
yeah it's been a lot of fun a lot of
hard work but a lot of a lot of fun with
uh you know collecting feedback seeing
real usage man there's nothing like that
feeling like you create something and
people are building real stuff in it we
have this university group that's doing
genomics research they're building
specialized medicine so they're doing
dna marker-based personalized medicine
and they're combining clinical trial
data with this you know dna marker
information that they have from their
genomics pipeline the fact that they're
building this out in orchards to me is
just mind-blowing it's so much so cool
to see very cool and is this a is this a
complicated workflow or what's um what's
the the most it's a combination of uh of
our code and then they have a little bit
of a user interaction bit because
they're basically building this as a
pipeline for
um
researchers that need to be able to
do like a guided analysis so they have
this one implementation of a pipeline
and then they collect during the
execution information from the
from the the person who has a data set
to analyze and then they collect some
information and then it does the second
phase of the pipeline so
yeah that's that's exciting
um so so on that note since that's just
a quick example of a real world use case
um
talk to us a little bit more in depth
about who you've discovered the optimal
users for this tool are like how are you
thinking about your ideal customer
profile and
um like who needs this most now
yeah so so obviously there are a lot of
tools available for people to choose
from and we like to define a pretty
narrow
set of criteria that people can use to
self-select to either not use orchestra
use orchest and so first of all you want
to
be a person that tries to analyze data
using code i know that there are many
tools that are about democratizing
access to data analysis and i think
these are really needed because a lot
more people need to be working with data
but i think it's really good to know
that if you build a tool that you have a
specific view of who is going to be
using it and so we're fully just
focusing on the coding user so we're not
any like we're not a low code tool so if
you're not analyzing the data in python
r or julia then you're probably not a
good fit for the orchest tool
so that's one thing second is you must
um
gain advantage from being able to work
with notebooks directly because some
people they just have this really very
rigid workflow in mind and they just
basically could write everything
in you know um non-exploratory ways but
they can just fully you know
ahead of time think about the data
transformations the type casting the you
know the the feature engineering and i
think if that's your situation you're
probably building a system for inference
or you're building a system for data
transforms that i think you're not
probably going to benefit as much from
the concepts in orcas because the
notebook doesn't really do much for you
maybe just gets in the way even
so that's i think another good
qualifying question like do you want to
use notebooks that being said we we see
that um the trade-off between scripts
and notebooks are more of a spectrum so
we have full support for scripts in in
orchest but we allow you to hand-pick
which parts of the pipeline will be a
notebook versus b script so often we see
data ingest for example is very often a
script it's just more convenient to
invoke a third-party api library using a
script and you could even make them make
them very generic and that's that's
that's very useful in like scripting but
a lot of times the model uh training the
data transforms data exploration that
can all be done uh with notebooks
so those are i would say are some of the
important criteria that we have for
people when they think about uh is
orchestra the right fit and i think it's
it's also good to highlight for example
some alternatives that we see a lot of
our users bump into
it's tools like five trend or stitch
stitch data where if you have a very
well-defined set of etl things that you
need to do where you're connecting one
sas tool to another and that workflow is
fully supported by these tools like five
transditch or matillion like it's
probably better to use them if all you
need to do is like that transformation
because they basically whenever you're
on the happy path i would say they give
you very good experience with it just
works out of the box thing but with
orchest you could do a lot more custom
things so basically when we ask our
users why did you choose orchest over
tools like those it's because they get a
lot more flexibility and very often uh
you might want to integrate with an api
that's like not supported in five train
or you might want to have some sort of
data training like a model training step
maybe to do like time series prediction
like that's often like to get
flexibility that's where orcas really
shines so i would say
notebooks
flexibility
and programmatic data analysis
and so the the con the the content of an
orchest
pipeline is
arbitrary
code scripts notebooks um in python only
or did you say that you can also handle
all languages so
so basically the the the key concept of
uh orcis is a is a dag a pipeline and
the pipeline steps are basically entry
points into containers as a user you
don't really know this you don't really
see it as much but basically you can
execute any containerized step in orcas
it's pretty similar to coop cloud in
that regard although in cupolo there's a
lot more like container awareness like
you need to image bundle and build your
own images for each step that's
definitely not how orcis was designed
you definitely you just work with
scripts itself you just work with a
python script or a notebook
behind the scenes yeah we basically
handle all the containerization and
image building and what this allows you
to do is to build very flexible
pipelines for example you could take
something like meltano as a ingest step
that invokes something on bash that
could just be a step in the pipeline
and then you could have a python
processing uh bit but you could actually
have you know a streamlit application at
the end so we're really about combining
a whole bunch of best-in-class open
source solutions in a very flexible
pipelining setup and the reason why we
see this working so well is because
oftentimes
you're kind of forced by your situation
to use a combination of things and in an
ideal world we would just be able to
work with a single python virtual
environment for everything but in
practice it's probably better to be at
the abstraction level of a container
could you you know if you need something
like graphviz as a system dependency
that's like fully supported in orcas so
um yeah it's very language agnostic we
support python r julia and bash and then
through bash you basically have a
gateway into like cpos plus scala or if
you need other
um esoteric choices
and so what about the notion of a
scheduler in orcas is that not as
important because of the exploratory
nature of
the way people are using the pipelines
or is that is that also a concept that
you support
so it's definitely important because
these pipelines they have all kinds of
complex interdependencies right so you
definitely want to execute the
graph in the order in which the
dependencies are defined so as a
scheduler we use salary in the
background so celery is a you know a
pretty simple task scheduler that's
python native and that interacts with
our container system so
it basically schedules containers for
execution but it's really important that
like when you when you build a pipeline
it might be what you wanted to do but
then you need to be able to
productionize it so we have the the
pipeline editing experience but then you
can also create a job and that runs it
on a scheduler including like a crown
based schedule where you could just say
run this on a sort of this frequency and
that really just gives you that um
batch
productionization that you want after
you've completed the pipeline so we
actually um in our template examples
that we give to users we often try to
make them item potent so you can run
them multiple times and they will still
succeed and i think this is one of the
biggest um
like the best things users and orcs can
do is write a pipeline that's item
potent schedule it as a job and then you
basically very easily are able to
productionize these pipelines and um
yeah it just works really well as a
system that way
very cool
um it sounds very flexible and that
you've you've thought through primitives
that are that are quite powerful i'm
sure people will be using this in
surprising ways that you probably
haven't even anticipated yet
yeah i think what's cool to see is that
if you create a bit of an open-ended and
generic system you can get surprised by
the people who use the product and i
think that's that's always good because
you really nobody really has all the
answers in this field and it's probably
you see this as well there are so many
approaches so many different tools and
we like to take a little bit more of an
approach of like we definitely don't
know it all and we try to be as
we try to assume as little as we can get
away with because then we leave room for
being wrong or even just being surprised
by different ways in which this these
tools can end up being helpful and um
yeah i think that's just that's just a
cool advantage of working with pretty
powerful primitives like you said i
think we we take an approach where we
try to make sure that best-in-class open
source solutions can be used within
orcist but we also build orcas using all
kinds of open source components so we
use for example the jupiter enterprise
gateway which is this generic wrapper
for running kernels as containers in a
cluster so basically it allows a gateway
between your notebook environment and
having the actual compute run somewhere
else on a on a different node as a
container because it's all networked and
like these types of lower level um
components really give that kind of
generic usefulness because we're not
necessarily like that actually supports
uh kernels in different languages so we
can have you know python kernels julia
kernels sql kernels it's really kind of
um
the genericness of it that can make it
universally useful
um
well those are yeah those are that's a
great way to articulate your product
values and i think
that makes a lot of sense
so um on that note are you supporting
or thinking about various kinds of
scale-out
decisions um or integrations with orcis
so that orcas can can integrate with
other aspects of the broader sort of
data science
compute system ecosystem
yeah so on the product side we're
actually in the process of moving away
from docker single node to kubernetes
distributed like basically cluster scale
running of the orcis pipelines we
already designed it in a way where
basically everything is encapsulated as
individual containers and that makes it
very easy to get free parallelization
because in your dag if you have multiple
steps that don't depend on each other we
can run those containers in parallel and
as long as those fit on a single node
you know you're happy because you get a
speed up but in a kubernetes cluster we
could even get that speed up um if it
saturates a node because we can move
them onto separate nodes and for that we
have to do the data marshalling which
gets the data from one step to the next
but that's been something for us that we
always wanted to work towards and so
what you then get is basically orcis as
a drop-in
system that you can just run on any
kubernetes cluster and so what we
typically see in terms of integration
with existing system is you have a
company they have a data stack and then
maybe in their virtual private cloud
environment or on-prem situation even
they have like an ability to run a
kubernetes cluster and now you could
just deploy orcas there as a native
kubernetes application but it can then
have network access to the ingest for
example so maybe you're running a
bigquery and gcp or maybe you're running
some sort of data warehouse where you
have the object storage
that's locally hosted as a local object
storage host sometimes for sensitive
data it makes a lot of sense and then
you tie into that existing data
infrastructure because you basically
become a drop in kubernetes deploy and i
think that's been the most interesting
thing that we've been working towards um
we have the orcas cloud basically to
make it super easy to try out the open
source project but now i think we'll be
much more easily you know deployable as
a solution in an existing context
because you could just drop it into this
existing managed kubernetes environment
or even a self-managed kubernetes but
basically we see kubernetes as a kind of
unified deployment plane for you know
distributed applications moving forward
um so so that's very exciting because it
gives you a lot of that node scale out
flexibility but it also sets the it puts
the compute of those data pipelines next
to where the data lives and i think
that's really big or like why don't you
run these things from your laptop it's
because the data sets could be really
large or like you could even work with
terra like like a billion rows
instructor data and you don't want to
have that over like the public network
to your machine so by by letting all the
data pipelines run in that same
environment uh as a kubernetes
application you could basically keep the
the computation and the data storage
very close together and it gives all
kinds of advantages
got it yeah that makes perfect sense
so i'm curious like what what are teams
doing that don't have access to orcas
like how do they
sort of hack together solutions or solve
these problems what what are you seeing
is the
sort of the the antithesis of this new
orkus dag data sciencey pipelining thing
that you've
that you've uh
that you've created
so you see various approaches and it
depends a lot on the situation of the
team so if it's like a very small team
they might just build something their
own uh themselves and it could just be
you know custom invocations of scripts
on like their own cloud environment so
sometimes they write lambda functions on
aws to do like something that's more
like a production style data processing
thing but sometimes people just work
directly on ec2 instances they might
have like the littlest jupiter hub as a
project where they self-host a jupiter
hub instance so they have these kind of
i think self-configured collection where
they combine a few open source projects
i don't think architecturally they're
very designed it's just like this kind
of works for us and at least the
computer is running in aws
and i think some people try to shoehorn
the data pipelining into regular
software ci cd so you just do like
github cicd pipelines or github actions
um i think generally speaking they're
really not
built for purpose so you get into a lot
of issues for example if you need
specific hardware like a gpu it's very
very tricky very nasty to get that to
work um and you also have companies that
have bigger initiatives that actually
just build full custom infra with
kubeflow or like something where they
basically go from the kubernetes layer
they introduce something like argo as a
scheduler they build stuff on stuff on
top but like to be honest like these are
like 6 to 12 months during builds
or builds that takes six to twelve
months and and they require very
specialist people so by the time people
commit to this kind of path they are
typically scratching their head and
going like oh should we really be
building this was that really the goal
of the data initiative but i think i
guess for some companies at scale that
makes sense um but what we're seeing is
a combination of those things got it
um we talked already or you mentioned
some of your
deployment enhancements um with
kubernetes et cetera are there any other
features that are upcoming in orcus that
you're excited about that you want to
mention
so one thing that we're excited about uh
in in orca's cloud is the auto start and
stop of the instances so what we really
didn't like so much about the lambda
experience if you've ever written like a
lambda service like a serverless feature
then you know how much it asks from your
traditional development process to
change right it's like forget all you
know forget everything this is how we're
going to build your serverless function
right right and and to me you know that
that makes sense as an investment
sometimes but not always and so what we
now have with orchest with this auto
starter stopping is because as an
application we understand your
your needs when you need to run because
it's a batch processing system we just
we can look at the job definition we can
infer when it needs to be executing we
could actually tear down and bring up
infrastructure automatically for you to
just run the instance and the nodes
whenever you have a job to process and
when it's done executing we just
automatically stop it for you and so
that allows us to get people to just
build pipelines using notebooks and then
they basically only have to uh
do it like a um sign up on a check mark
that says auto start and stop this
instance and then they only pay for the
compute during execution but they could
just be coding in jupyter notebooks and
i think this like
do what you're already doing and then we
make it a lot smarter for you without
you having to do any additional work
that's been kind of like a core product
in it for us um and and just being able
to ship this soon i think is pretty
exciting in addition to the the
multi-node stuff
very cool
great rick well um yeah i really really
appreciate you sharing about orchest
with us and um i'm curious we have to
let you go soon but um what's the
biggest vision for orchest and its
products
for us we actually want to take the
like where we started with the
abstraction layers we actually want to
take that much further than just like
letting people use notebooks i think
what's really interesting is how can we
keep redefining
how you interface with your data and how
you bring that to production and how you
iterate on that as you learn from actual
production use and like do that at an
abstraction layer that just works really
well for the type of people that are in
these roles i think it's really good to
remember that the typical
person you find in the industry that's
analyzing data that's creating
predictive models that they don't
necessarily want to become like
full-blown software engineers i think
they all kind of wish they didn't have
to do all that stuff
i think
that's to us really important that we
like you now have to think about cuda
driver versions and like your installed
package to make sure it matches up to be
able to get the compute to run i think
it's pretty uh insane that data
scientists actually need to know about
that kind of low level stuff and so for
us it's really on a journey to keep
moving that abstraction layer up and up
so that they can really just be in the
in the domain that they actually wanted
to be in the first place which is
thinking about the data how does it
relate to the business how can we
actually put that as a model in
production and and what can we actually
say from the inference that we can do
and i think that's trust like it's
definitely a journey we won't be there
with the first you know iteration of
orcas won't be there with the first
products that we're working on but i
think there's always i think we should
everyone and the industry should be
pushing towards this
where those abstractions allow people to
get more and more done
while at the same time knowing less
about the lower level things that are
going on i mean it's it's similar to
instructions as architects you had
people coding an assembly how how crazy
is that like nobody would do that today
right you you're in python you're in
high-level languages and i think there's
there are there are layers of
abstractions to create data science but
we're all just figuring out what they
are actually going to look like and i
think you know dags are a nice first
step but
there's so much more to do there yeah
yeah that's well said
well um rick i'm curious uh
just as sort of a final question um
what are the key things that you've
learned or surprises that you've you've
gathered from your work in the data
tooling ecosystem so far
i think
what's interesting is the distribution
it's actually something that andrew eng
uh highlighted in his um
newsletter it's the batch it's really
good you should all follow that but
basically he talks about how
you know there are these really obvious
data use cases and they're like super
big like netflix
um
recommendation right it's like a very
core thing to their business but i think
there's this uh very interesting
long-tailed as he refers to it of all
these data problems that are really
worth solving and in aggregate they're
very valuable to solve but it's really
hard to
um
to to dedicate the resources and to work
efficiently enough to be able to make
sense to to go and attack all those like
more minor use cases and i think the
what we're seeing as we're talking to
people in the industry as we're talking
to our users
um we're learning more and more that
they're different like there are all
these different flavors of these these
problems that people are working on and
that we can do much more to make it
like maybe ten times as uh cheap to
solve these
use cases by just abstracting and
generalizing and i think the
the the the sheer volume and the share
you know diversity but also just like
the prevalence of all these types of
things that could could be done using
data that's already out there like
operational data data and existing
systems and just looking at that data
sometimes even and and
getting that data to the right person in
the company could be a total game
changer if done at scale and i think
that's something we've learned where
it's not necessarily interesting to
chase the one predictive model with like
a
billion train points and like 500 gpus
that trained it it's actually
interesting how can we systematically
attack all these good data opportunities
that are
maybe small individually but in
aggregate are very meaningful
um and that that trend i think he put it
really well but it's something we're
seeing in the um
in the industry with our users yeah
yeah interesting
um i i agree with that and and hopefully
folks will be able to use tools like
orchest and
um and or or the other um dozens
hundreds of other tools out there as you
and i were talking about earlier um to
start to solve some of these longer tail
problems at scale
um well rick thanks for joining us if
people have more questions for you
um how can they reach you
uh they can find me on twitter uh it's
just my full name rick glammers uh or on
linkedin okay awesome well thanks for
joining us rick
thanks for having me
and to our listeners uh thank you for
tuning in again we'll have another
episode
in two weeks on december 2nd where i'll
be chatting with graeme thompson from
privacy dynamics on privacy safe data
engineering so make sure to join us then
and